she's saying like if you're sleeping
around now like then that like um i
think that's really reductionist um so
if you knew me
i was suicidal i tried to kill myself a
couple of times um and so if you knew me
who i was um even a year ago no not
actually not a year ago year ago was
good but two years ago i was very
codependent i was very i had very low
self-worth i had and so to be like your
past actions determine who you are no
you've spoke about self-awareness
you can't say if a guy went to prison
three times for for
attempted battery he might do it again
oh no 100 i understand like you you can
say that you can't say that but to
reduce a woman to be like oh just
because so i was very codependent and so
the men i date now
would be like well based on your history
you want a relationship with me you're
going to fall in love with me and i'm
like you are very confused i don't want
that at all right now i will because i'm
very different
i've been i've been single by choice for
a year and a half like that's not a bad
thing it's okay to like fall in love
like a year and a half it's been a year
and a half and i've not yeah yeah but
but i'm i'm saying like
can i ask you a question
if you met a guy that you really liked
and you were considering him for a
relationship
and he told you that he had cheated in
every relationship previous to this
are you saying that would not at all
impact his desirability to you
for a boyfriend no i'm not saying that
i'm not again that's it it's not black
and white it's not one-size-fits-all i
will i will keep saying until i'm
growing i'm blue in the face it's not
one-size-fits-all it's really not saying
not saying that it'd be like not saying
it's the deciding factor but like
would it not shift your opinion of him
potentially as a boyfriend or do you
think that would not impact your view of
him at all no no being being realistic
yeah he would be being a realist yeah
and the same way so you'd understand if
a guy viewed like
basically sleeping around a lot the same
way but then we've got yeah yeah but
then we've got
um if you have like 500 days of summer
it's one of my favorite films and she
says when you know you know and i've
dated a lot of guys who are like i'm
never gonna be relation i'm never gonna
i was like well you will you will meet
someone at some point in your life it's
probably inevitable i know that you will
meet someone that you're like i'm to
settle down i don't agree with when you
know you know i think that you make a
choice
and like that's it like i don't think
most people well yeah when you know that
it's the right choice but i'm saying i
don't think you'll ever know and i think
that's like a lot of like now fear today
and like dating today is people thinking
that they're just gonna they're just
gonna know but all you can do is make a
decision with the information that you
have but then yeah but then you'll know
that like
and even nowadays like people are dating
like what a decade five years three
years before they decide to get married
do you think those people just knew if
they're dating three like
three years like i don't think they know
it's the one i don't believe in the one
but i think they know that they
especially and so it that research shows
that women will kind of um
look for that long term men will get to
a point where they're suddenly like oh
[ __ ] i kind of need to settle down now
ergo i'm gonna look right if she's here
and she fits in she'll do so men
actually technically end up settling and
they don't know why is that one why is
it settling it's no it's it's they just
made a choice they said okay yeah i'm
looking to like get married in this time
frame this girl fits everything i i i'm
looking for but she doesn't necessarily
fit everything i'm looking for that's
why it's because people aren't perfect
so so i don't i don't think it's really
settling if you say okay she doesn't
have everything like it's kind of like
do you know what she'll do yeah she'll
do it i think women could be better but
she'll do yeah but i think women like
probably could you know have a little
bit more he'll do yeah yeah i don't
think that's a bad thing because i'm not
perfect yeah i can't expect the guy dave
to be perfect
and so like
yeah like i just i don't like the word
settling it's not settling i i i agree
because especially with like romance and
like novels and like films and stuff you
believe that there's this idea of the
one and i know and it's like you
actually don't you actually just need to
be okay with what is and what's
happening and be like will you want more
probably a lot of people in
relationships in marriages you can ask
someone to be like what do you love
about your partner what do you not love
what do you wish was different like even
i would not date a snorer and that is
and that's uh if you don't have a
driver's license and you snore and
people like well that's not made
people's fault doesn't it i was like i
literally know that i would want to kill
you if both of those things weren't a
thing yeah but if i really loved a guy
then i'd be like well [ __ ] it i don't
care i don't know i say like girls have
all these standards till they met the
guy that makes them not care
but then it's like well do i do i know
or am i like yeah here's
i always say i'd be the type i swear to
god i'd get married in six months
because i feel like
there's risk there's risk regardless
i'd rather just do it and hope for the
best and if it doesn't i'll get divor
like but like i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna go into something
like okay being afraid of divorce
whatever it happens i hope it doesn't
happen to me like do you think you would
be more afraid of divorce if you're a
man
oh yeah i absolutely would yeah
because mine gets screwed over so oh
actually no no i got i got
i'm in this situation i should be afraid
i should be afraid
you should actually yeah you should but
nah i mean i think like again there's
risk with everything like so you think
if you're if you're a man you would look
at marriage as openly as you do now
um
probably not probably not i have a
question do you think your dad if he was
in our generation would get married
today yes you think he did yeah he he
wants my brother to get married oh wow
no i mean my dad my parents are more
like traditional so oh that's great
like i don't know i think there's a lot
of legal issues and problems that like
i'll advocate for for matt like they're
not
represented fairly in court like i don't
i don't think that you should be able to
take half a man's income just because
you had a kid together yeah
i think i'll be i think the laws are
only going to change
in
not the next generation next donation
after because a lot of men are saying
they're not going to get married because
of it and i think because women still
want to get married they're going to
start advocating for those laws to
change yeah no probably i think that's
right what are you going to say just
quickly
piggybacking off of that i think a lot
of like yeah you're saying men don't
want to get married women do and there's
a lot there is a lot of dependency upon
like taking a man's name and like
getting a mortgage all that stuff but i
really want to know how do you feel
about like
dad's giving their daughter away
oh i think it's a really cute treat i
wish i would i tell my dad i was i tell
him he could pick out my husband all the
time he doesn't want to though he says
i've got i'm busy
so for me it'd be nice if he's like no
i'm not going to pick your husband you
pick someone that you think is well
that's kind of what he does he's like
because if it goes wrong you'll blame me
i have to meet your dad at some point if
he's ever in london you have to tell me
oh no
and you know i know from that's it my
own bias and my like poor relation with
my dad i'm like i hate the idea of
belonging to a man and being given to a
man but i know that actually if i had a
good relationship with my dad i'd
probably be in your shoes i'd probably
yeah oh it's actually really sweet i
mean because you're i think like as
women i mean
we're attracted to shitty traits and we
can't really help it like i'm
freud we have a field day no like we
like [ __ ] we do i mean and i
understand like the science of why it's
like the dark triad traits like the same
trait yeah can you can you define the
dart track because i only discovered
this recently oh god i don't remember it
off the top of my head but it's like
like a guy that's aggressive right like
why do women stay with the men that like
beat them because the same men that like
are aggressive and like beat them can
also beat up someone else so it's the
same trait right a guy
like a guy that's controlling right he
also can control the environment yep
yeah so it's i don't remember all of
them but it's like it's like the same
traits that make a guy like completely
like an awful like partner also make him
a really good one yeah so i i have a
question for the ladies on the panel um
if you know that this is what you're
attracted to why do you think so many
women say they just want a nice guy
i don't think they realize that they
think so do you yeah i was gonna so my
next question was do you think a lot of
women are unaware of what they're
actually attracted to yes
yes i really think it comes from
inexperience because
at the end of the day being nice is not
enough it's really not enough it's the
bare minimum it's like breathing it's
like i don't think being nice is
actually i'd admired to be honest like a
bit like condition like unconditional
kindness from a man i think is seen as
weakness because well it's because like
it's a guy that doesn't like because a
lot of times this is this is my
experience a lot of times guys will say
they're nice but they're not they're not
actually nice
they're not nice they're afraid to stand
up for themselves and they're they like
we don't like guys that put us on a
pedestal like why do we think we like
like guys that make fun of us a little
bit yeah because you're treating us like
we're human so if we say something dumb
and you call it like
you know yeah or they think they're nice
because they're like well i'm not raping
someone i'm not beating you up er go i'm
nice and i'm like
i've
[Applause]
experience but yeah no i think everyone
guys say they're nice they're like i've
given her everything i take her here i
do this i do this
i think it's a lot of guys that go above
and beyond for women but women don't
respect guys that give them everything
without making them earn it but then we
get in cell culture
and so it's like men who are like i'm
xyz it's like you're not though you're
not as good as you think you are you are
the best being nice is the best well i
think incels are kind of a result of
women not settling
and like like women saying i'd rather be
alone than have to settle instead of
like i don't know and then this goes
back to i actually think men are not i
actually think
i actually think as much as i'm for
female empowerment and like i actually
think men end up settling more
and i think men actually end up
disappointing themselves more being like
if you asked a man write down your
perfect woman on paper and let's compare
it to the woman that you ended up with
i think that yeah i think a lot more
women are actually like i'd rather be
alone than settle but then it's like you
actually could be alone forever if
you're not willing to settle if you're
not
but you can but you can't you can but
then you'll be homeless yeah yeah for
most women do you need 2.5 million to
retire
um
i think in regards to men settling i
think that i think men just don't have a
lot on their list
for women i think they just want
honestly i think
i think the majority of men in terms of
long term just want a woman who's warm
kind and peaceful
um and as if she's that with a low body
count
[Music]
well yeah ideally i think ideally but i
think even if she i think that's i think
that is a preference but i think i think
the difference is like men don't have a
lot of
conditional points whereas i think a lot
of women have conditionals so a lot of
women will make their preference as part
of the condition
you know so ishima okay a guy has to be
six foot if he's not six foot i'm not
gonna entertain him whereas a guy might
be like okay i'd rather she's
four inches shorter than me but she's
the same height i can live with that
i think that's do you know what i mean
so i think all of them make their
preference i've never had a guy reject
me